adam wainwright appearing with yadier
molina for the 277th
career start as battery mates
that is ranked sixth all-time
in major league history and yachty is
about to make history with the first
pitch of this ball game
it is going to be game 2000 behind the
play for yadier molina the first pitch
by wainwright
and with that pitch
yadier molina becomes the first catcher
in major league history with 2 000 games
caught with one team
just the sixth catcher overall to get to
this incredible milestone 2000 games as
a
other
catcher
in major league baseball history to
catch 2 000 games
and he's the only catcher in history to
accomplish that feat
with only one team
congratulations
held on to by molina and his strikeout
of soto
first of the afternoon for adam
wainwright joe ross pitched friday five
innings took a no decision against the
la dodgers in the rotation for the
nationals
and yachty hits it into center and a
base hit
you know his family is so proud today to
see what's happened here with yadier
molina if you combine the brothers jose
benji and yachty
it's 4
200 games caught in the major leagues
what a family
daryl kyle the late daryl kyle who
pitched for the cardinals had a nasty
12-6 curveball yes he did
and this one lifted to center
and it's on the ground it's behind lane
thomas
harrison around the third checking in
with a double starlin castro
the o2 pitch
and that'll be a strikeout for adam
wainwright
the next two robles sway and a miss he
struck him out
back-to-back case for wayne oh gets out
of the jam
the nationals strand the bases loaded
soto puts it in play
bare hand and that would have had to
have been a tremendous play by
aeronautica should be a hit all the way
for juan soto
and here's ryan zimmerman who popped up
to the second baseman first time up
and zimmerman makes a loud noise out to
left center
it is
see
you
later
hit either the very top of the wall or
just beyond it and the next lead two
nothing ryan's first homer and rbi's of
the year
harrison rips one by goldsmith
on base two more times
and josh harrison is five out of nine in
this series
throwing in their hotel rooms into
mattresses
3-2 and a base hit for tommy edmond off
to the races down into the corner
dug out by soto
edmonds stops at second base
it's a one out double hitting straight
at 10 and counting
really expand with the slider away here
if they decide to off the plate there it
is beauty
goldsmith no chance
oh that's some run back for the
strikeout a beauty
slider nasty you know what they're
saying in st louis right now
after 14 runs last night this is
happening well you're looking at the
reason his name's joe ross if drake
turner can get untracked a couple of
ground ball outs
adam wainwright 66 pitches through four
innings
trey the other way hit well moving away
from the right fielder
edmund knocks it down and trey turner
with an opposite field approach early in
the count goes to second base
now juan soto going to try to pull a
baseball here to advance his buddy on
second and soto takes the breaking ball
right up the middle oh and then a boot
by thomas
turner scores easily juan soto heading
for third
nationals lead three nothing
what a piece of hitting by juan said are
you kidding me
josh harrison will try and get soda home
from third 2-0 pitch breaking ball line
drive up the middle one hopping through
a base hitter to center field for
harrison in from third to score is soto
two runs home in the inning and it's now
the nationals four
and the cardinals nothing
oh fastball up
and joe ross bumps it for a fair ball
down the right field line
how about that what else could he do
today and maybe that's why he did get a
slider but the base is full
the 0-1
swinging a crown ball third base side
arnotto has it to second for one
carpenter to first is not in time
and a run will score
crossing the plate is joe ross over to
third is robles soto now leads the club
with seven rbis
the nationals tack on one to lead five
nothing
tyler webb up and throwing in the pin
pick off at second got him he's out
cyril runs
into the out at second and takes
washington out of the inning
in the air left center well hit
and it's off the wall for nolan arenado
digging into second and in there safely
basketball blows him away joe ross
ladies and gentlemen strikeout number
five
scattering three hits make it four today
he now has 11 consecutive scoreless
innings
treya walk a run
after the double
and his breaking ball
gallegos skying out to left center
they're looking at each other and the
ball drops
turner hustling into second appears to
be safe
and the nats lead six to nothing
as a bunch of birds
didn't pick that one out of the sky they
just all kind of shortened up and
stopped but they've been doing this all
day they've been flirting with this play
all day long
that's a well-placed hook here comes
robles
nice
lack of suspense
late in the game by the nationals
bullpen ball game goes about three hours
and 11 minutes and the nets get a
shutout
joe ross set the tone early fp and now
they beat the cardinals 6-0